what was the schedule with that saturday
night live the week of uh of last week
like preparing for snl is uh
[ __ ] nuts dude it's [ __ ] it's
literally alien i mean i cried every
single day of the week no joke at all
yeah you cried every single day of the
week because you felt insecure about
acting or acting in a comedy uh kind of
situation what was that yeah i did
actually love to act when i was a kid um
but i don't i'm not that's not my world
so i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm doing
like i don't i i feel
like i i'm terrible i feel like i'm i
suck and
the uh the craziest part of the week was
on i think it was tuesday wednesday
the table read where
everybody
reads
60 i think maybe 50 40 i don't a lot
of scripts at a table
why do they have you at the table for
the table read first of all it's with
the whole cast
so so all the scripts that are written
everybody has a part so i was in all of
them so i had to read my my part in all
of them
and um
you know you do it for like a few hours
however long it takes and then there's
like a 20-minute break in the middle and
then you do the rest so you do like 20
scripts
and then stop for a second and then 20
more and in the break i cried and came
back
like he went to the room cried and came
back you went to the green
it's snl it's like these
amazingly talented actors ev surrounding
a table
where somehow i'm the
main course
at this
for this show
i didn't feel like qualified for
and
oh i i don't know
i totally get what you're saying i mean
you when you're like with next to a kate
mckinnon who is so crazy talented it
would be analogous if i got to one of
your concerts and you said hey howard
come up and sing you know i'd be like i
don't think you know but you know i felt
when you came out and did the monologue
you were as loose as a goose i didn't
sense nervousness were you internally
like ready to throw up or were you just
all of a sudden calm
you know what's actually funny is that i
was ready to throw up i actually did
throw up because of it uh oh i didn't
know that well i i had many i had like a
[ __ ] dude
i
had a
full body reaction to
being anxious about this the whole week
i mean like threw up on the plane coming
here
uh she
had crazy shits when i got here like you
would not believe
crazy [ __ ] and yeah yeah wow um what
kind of [ __ ] to get fully naked on the
toilet
right because it's a mess i literally
did i don't know that's never like that
i don't that's not a usual thing and i'm
sorry to bring this up for people oh
i've had i've had crazy shits i know
what you're thinking about yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
they need to be normalized you got to
talk about them yeah we're human we're
human i really had a and it was a crazy
stomach i just i've had stomach because
all week i've been anxious and nervous
and like
just because that's not my it's not my
world and i'm so petrified of people
thinking that i'm i suck
um yeah that i just you don't want to do
it but you know what billy billy why put
yourself through it like if you were
just a musical guest again
you probably would have been okay right
you wouldn't have been as nervous
because that's your you know you're
doing a song why put yourself through
being the host
if you're going to be [ __ ]
and vomiting and i mean i mean that's a
violent physical reaction as soon as we
got to the dress rehearsal where there
was actually an audience i walked out on
stage and before i opened the door you
know up at the top of the stage i was
like shivering and shaking and nervous
and right before i opened it i was like
and then i opened the door
and as soon as i saw the crowd and felt
their
joy
i it was like i wasn't nervous like i
suddenly was like ah like
it was relieving somehow and i think
that that is just my
my love for performing and then i was
like oh this is actually really
incredible
and i don't have to worry this is just
for fun